[موسيقى]
في العشرين من مايو الماضي دخلت كاميرا
قناه العربيه الى مستشفى الضعين بشرق
دارفور غربيه السودان ووقفت علامه يدور
داخل قسم الاطفال بمستشفى الضعين وقتها
كانت نسبه وفيات حديثيه الولاده اكثر من
ثلاثين طفلا منذ بدايه ازمه الاكسجين
والكهرباء بهذا المستشفى وعندما تم بث
التقرير تدخلت السلطات المحليه بمستشفى
الضعين ومنظمات تعمل في مجال الاطفال وتم
توفير خط ساخن للكهرباء لهذا المستشفى كما
تم توفير نسبه مقدره من الاكسجين للاطفال
في خط كهرباء ساخن للمستشفى 24 ساعه رغم
انقطاع الطعم للتيار الكهربائي في الولايه
شركه دارفور لكن المستشفى تنعم بالكهرباء
نساهم كثير في خفض عض وفيات حديث الولاده
ممكن تكون لزيرو لانه هي المشكله الاساسيه
كان الكهرباء
والاكسين بعد هذه التدخلات اليوم انخفضت
نسبه وفيات الاطفال بصوره كبيره
لوحه العنابر شبه خاليه بسبب الاستجابه
السريعه للعلاج كهرباء الحمد لله يتوفرت
الناس الى الانخفاض يعني الوفيات يتخفضت
ويتقللت يمكن اقول لك بعد اسبوع يمكن يكون
حاله وفاه يمكن يكون واحده او اقل من وما
زالت المبادره المجتمعيه تعمل داخل
المستشفى وهذه هي جامعه الضعين وغرفه
الطوارئ تنفذ حمله للنظافه ونقل النفايات
المقدسه منذ فتره طويله داخل المستشفى
تدخلنا ان شاء الله بعض الايات اني احاول
احاول ردمها وحرقها والتخلص منها ان شاء
الله المبادره حتنطلق مع مبادره غرفه
طوارئ انه نحاول انه نعمل غرف ان شاء الله
ببعض الاطراف المدينه زي معسكر النيم زي
معسكر خوري عمر لان في اقتصار سكاني كبير
جدا ننتقل للمحليات ويواجه مستشفى الضعين
ضغطا كبيرا في الخدمات المقدمه نسبه
لزيارات المتعدده للمرضى من مختلف
الولايات السودان الشيء الذي يحتاج الى
دعم اكبر خلال هذه الفتره صالح ابو علامه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات